servus Leute und herzlich willkommen vom
Oktoberfest ich bin heute nicht alleine
hier bei diesem wunderschönen Wetter
sondern ich habe einen münchenexperte an
meiner Seite was geht ab habe die Ehre
Franklin ist hier heute mal ganz anderes
Video bisschen Vlogs Style Franklin darf
heute von den ganzen Köstlichkeiten denn
das ist unsere heutige Mission und über
das Oktoberfest zu essen darf er nicht
essen warum kannst du ja selbst kurz
sagen ich es aktuell einen Monat nur
Döner und ich habe noch 7 Tage vor mir
und ich beende die Streak nicht jetzt
tut mir leid ich will auf jeden Fall
heute die ganze Oktoberfest Bandbreite
erleben wir beginnen mit dem schönen
Kaiserschnitt
oh mein Gott aber drin oder draußen okay
wir suchen uns was schönes ist die
heutigen übrigens für Kaiserschmarrn
aber doch nicht ein kaiserschmarnzellen
ja sozusagen griechischer die haben so
auf Kaiserschmarren spezialisiert sage
ich mal ein bisschen und hier werde ich
heute Abend sein paulanerzelt da kommt
vielleicht was auf Reals oder Shorts
oder so das wird deshalb erstmal eine
gute Grundlage schaffen suchen wir uns
einen leckeren Kaiserschmarrn
[Musik]
so muss er gemacht werden dass er
richtig geil wird Freunde wir sind jetzt
hier im ersten Zelt angekommen und es
gibt einfach nur Süßspeisen es sieht aus
wie in irgendeinem Märchen irgendwie so
wie ein Lebkuchenhaus wir stellen uns
jetzt einen Kaiserschmarrn Franklins
Lieblingsessen also einzeln und dazu
noch ein paar Weißwürste das heißt alles
in allem auf jeden Fall ein ordentlicher
Start in den Tag genau wir sind die
Weißwürste ganz schön teuer muss man
sagen 15,80 € für zwei weiße Stunde
ist auch nicht ganz günstig aber wir
sind auf dem Oktoberfest daran werde ich
mich heute gewöhnen müssen gleich geht
hier die Live Musik los deshalb
vielleicht wird's ein bisschen lauter
aber es wird auf jeden Fall lecker los
geht's
das ist der kulinarische Einstieg ins
Oktoberfest ein Kaiserschmarrn
Apfelkompott dazu und so wie der riecht
kann er nur lecker sein teuer ist auf
jeden Fall
[Musik]
ich habe auch schon sehr guten
Kaiserschmarrn in Wien gegessen der war
natürlich noch mal eine Ecke besser aber
der hat auf seine eigene Art und Weise
wirklich vieles was er richtig macht der
schmeckt so richtig so kompakt und dicht
und zeigen nicht ganz so fluffig mir
vielleicht sein könnte aber mit diesem
Puderzucker oben drauf einfach krass wie
gerne würde wir stehen jetzt gerade
Essen Kaiserschmarrn ist mein
Lieblingsessen von allen ja also ich
ignoriere einfach aber das muss ich
wirklich sagen wo ist ein Respekt an
Franklin wenn der sagt er ist 30 Tage
Döner dann ist er auch 30 Tage Döner
also nichts anderes ja dafür wir haben
schon geschafft es gibt leider keinen
Wiesen Döner hier ich esse mich hier ein
bisschen durch und gleich bekommen
Freunde das Video wird heute auf jeden
Fall ganz anders weil die ganze
Geräuschkulisse in den Zelten und so ist
kompliziert wir müssen da zusammen durch
wir schaffen das aber danke schön
da sind die Münchner reise ich will auch
sagen ehrlich gesagt die kriegst du hier
überall auf dem Oktoberfest die stabil
sind überall die gleichen wahrscheinlich
oder ähnliches oder
sowohl Brezen als auch
im Oktoberfest ja also hier muss ich
schon wirklich sagen 15 € für zwei
Weißwürste und eigentlich eine Brezel
das ist auf jeden Fall nicht gerade weil
ich habe noch nie eine Weißwurst auf dem
Oktoberfest gegessen
ohne Witz die ist wirklich gut also das
ist eh verpönt glaube ich in Bayern aber
wir haben eine Zeit lang bei uns im Büro
mit Dave auch Weißwurstfrühstück gemacht
immer haben wir jeden Dienstag
alkoholfreies Weißbier Weißwürste und
Brezen gekauft einfach so weil wir auf
dumm das mal angefangen haben und da
haben wir halt so normale Supermarkt
Weißwürste gegessen und diese hier sind
wirklich gut dann schmeckt so diese
Petersilie raus die Gewürze raus das
geil und das hier davon glaube ich auch
nicht auf die leichte Schulter neben mir
auf dem Oktoberfest eine Brezel und
ehrlich zu sein die fühlt sich nicht
irgendwie besonders an also die fühlt
sich also die ist jetzt nicht knusprig
oder irgendwas die Brezel holt mich
nicht ab also ich glaube es gibt so
richtige Oktoberfest Brezen ja Wiesen
vielleicht probieren wir später noch mal
eine wiesenbräter damit wir wissen dass
der real deal ist das hier ist eine
standardbrietze also die kriegt man so
auch in Köln aber die Weißfluss war geil
der Kaiserschmarrn war geil das man
guter Start wir verdrücken jetzt noch
ein bisschen was und dann geht's zum
nächsten Mal der max hat gemeint für
brechen jetzt auf ja und äh damit wir
heute auch ein kleinen Bay Kurs hast ich
wenn du gehst sagst du in Zukunft
backmas bevor es uns da packt backmas
bevor es uns verpackt auf wie geil so
Freunde nächste Station Wetter ist immer
noch traumhaft Ochsenbraterei Rose
ochsensemmel geben soll oh guckt euch
dieses Bild mal wieder an da oben der
erste ist mal Festzelt das sieht schon
wieder ganz anders aus hier ah
ochsensemmel Verkauf und hier gibt es
die ochsensemmel ein ganzer Ochse der
sich da dreht in irgendein
wahrscheinlich eigens konstruierten
Vorrichtung da ist er also der
ochsensemmel
schauen wir einmal gemeinsam rein wir
haben saure Gurken so eine Art Käsesoße
vielleicht eine rote Soße dann natürlich
den Ochsen
ist in dem Brot was wirklich
aussieht also es ist fast ein Döner
oben auf der Oberseite deshalb habe ich
leider auch die Geste gemacht ist das
Brot wirklich sehr sehr knackig die
Unterseite dagegen ist mega fluffig also
wirklich Crunch man hat diese
Flüssigkeit die Soße ist eine Mischung
aus süßem senften scharfen Senf und
vielleicht sowas wie Ketchup oder so und
der Bezug für Ochse ist von der
Konsistenz her auch wirklich was
besonderes habe ich so noch nie gegessen
so noch nie gesehen und ich glaube das
gibt's auch nicht über den ganzen außen
zu verwerfen schaffst du halt nur wenn
du so viel Leute im Hintergrund hast
deshalb ein musterfest ist ich finde es
richtig gut danke dass du es mir gezeigt
hast also wir kriegen jetzt frisch aus
dem Ofen hier eine ausgezogen ne dann
scheint auch ein Klassiker ist das ein
Oktoberfest Ding oder generell Bayern
und München wahrscheinlich
alles an hat frage ich mich da wir haben
in der Mitte so ein etwas helleres Stück
ich weiß nicht das kommt wahrscheinlich
durch die Art und Weise wie es gebacken
wird kommt frisch aus dem Ofen und
duftet wirklich unfassbar gut ich meine
wie soll so ein frisch frittiertes
Gebäck wohl riechen wir braucht man
eigentlich irgendwie so ein Pott Kaffee
oder so dann kann man es richtig
genießen so ist es aber auf jeden Fall
eine süße klassisch bayerische
Abwechslung für zwischendurch zum
Oktoberfest muss ich wirklich sagen es
ist halt Festessen ne es ist Essen das
ist fettig das ist süß das ist groß dass
es viel so das macht einfach Bock also
ich kann mich da sehr für begeistern und
man kann tatsächlich nicht nur Bier
trinken auf dem Oktoberfest sondern auch
echt leckere Sachen essen so Freunde
jetzt kommt es zum vorläufigen Höhepunkt
vom heutigen Video hinter uns ist das äh
käferzelt bekannt für ja hohe Preise und
aber auch gutes Essen oder das teuer
mit der besten ja und eine Sache muss
man essen wenn man auf dem Oktoberfest
ist und das ist auch Schweinshaxen mit
Klöße war das gut war das bayerisch
Scheiße Alter ich habe gedacht
wie sagt man es auch auf jeden Fall Box
gibt so viel essen hier
das ist die Speisekarte
[Musik]
der sieht richtig gut aus dieser Kruste
ohne Witz Freunde ich glaube jetzt
wird's noch mal richtig schwer für
Franklin
hier was ich vor mir habe ist für mich
Oktoberfest pur ein Schweinsbraten mit
einer schönen knackigen Kruste dazu zwei
Klöße Knödel
haben ein bisschen und ich kann es mir
nicht vorstellen wie lecker das sein
wird ich weiß nur dass dieser
Apfelschorle und
eine 44 € gekostet haben
[Musik]
wenn man jetzt noch Interesse hat und
dann kommt dieses
ganze
professionell Leute
komplett ab
[Musik]
. das richtig also das ist halt auch
eine der wurde das ist auch keine
rechtfertige
aber
sehr sehr teuer
sag mal bevor es uns verpackt
Freunde das war lecker aber es war auch
verdammt teuer so wie eigentlich alles
heute und ich muss euch ganz ehrlich
sagen heute habe ich keinen Erik dabei
heute kann mir auch Franklin nicht
helfen ich bin einfach randvoll deshalb
belasse ich dabei ich glaube ich habe
eine gute Idee bekommen wie das
Oktoberfest schmeckt wir haben wirklich
köstliche Dinge ich sage immer wir ich
habe köstliche Dinge gegessen falls ihr
Franklins Meinung zu dem Ochsen zupfen
ochsensible wissen wollt dann schaut bei
ihm vorbei ich habe aber das Gefühl dass
sie jetzt eine sehr gute Grundlage für
heute Abend wenn es für mich ins
Paulaner Zelt geht deshalb danke fürs
zusehen danke dir Franklin für die Hilfe
weil ohne dich hätte ich glaube nicht so
guten Einblick bekommen wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Video wieder bis dahin
macht's gut ciao ciao